the shores of northern lebanon have
become part of a route for refugees and
migrants bound for europe
four months ago a tragedy at sea
highlighted the desperation among an
increasingly impoverished population
now survivors have returned to the site
of the shipwreck about six kilometers
off the coast
at least 30 members of their families
among them children are still missing
with a submarine paid for by donations
an operation is underway to try to
retrieve bodies that could still be
inside the boat
450 meters below sea
the lebanese government did not do its
duty towards his people and it is
because of them these people died they
wanted a better life
salam and rania were among those who
drowned
their mother baria survived
along with her two sons and future
son-in-law she and her two daughters had
hoped to reach italy to escape a life of
poverty and unemployment
there are conflicting reports on what
caused the boat to sink when it was
intercepted by the lebanese army but
families want closure
hello
even if it's just one bone i want it a
shoe a sweater whatever it is it belongs
to my daughters and i want it
the tragedy hasn't stopped lebanese from
trying to reach europe by sea earlier
this month 75 people were rescued from a
sinking boat off the coast of turkey
authorities say illegal migration has
been increasing steadily
at least 3 000 people are believed to
have tried or were able to reach europe
in the past six months and unlike in the
past most people risking the journey are
lebanese not syrian or palestinian
refugees
i will make another attempt to leave and
another i won't stop until i leave this
country
you live without any dignity here
there's helplessness and concern for the
future but most of all there is grief
senator al-jazeera off the coast of
northern lebanon